bonjour gibert bejjani merci de répondre
à nos questions ce matin sur rtl france
en france le 9 juin c'est la troisième
étape du déconfinement avec notamment le
couvre-feu retardé à 23h ou encore
l'augmentation des jauges d'accueil par
exemple en belgique mercredi donc le 9
juin et il ya aussi des restrictions qui
seront levés au regard de la situation
épidémique dans votre pays c'est une
bonne ou c'est une mauvaise chose selon
vous c'est une très bonne chose
nous attendons depuis un petit temps en
tout cas la population l'attend et je
pense que les chiffres sont très
positifs et permettent cela dès le mois
de juillet les 16 17 ans vont pouvoir se
faire vacciner en belgique comment
est-ce que vous acquérez cette décision
très bien en fait ça va faciliter la vie
la vie des familles ça va augmenter le
taux vaccinale global on sait très bien
qu'il ya des personnes qui ont refusé de
se faire vacciner mais pour assurer la
protection de la société dans son
ensemble il faut que la couverture soit
plutôt proche des 80 % donc aujourd'hui
en belgique sûrement un peu plus de 40%
de la population totale
il ya eu sa première d'août une
vingtaine de pourcents qui a eu ses deux
doses évidemment les très bonnes pour
les personnes à risque comme guy
puisqu'on a dépassé les 80% on est à 80
3% et qu'elle est très bonne pour une
personne âgée
donc on est à un bon 60% pour les
personnes de plus de 65 ans donc ce sont
des bons chiffres mais à voyeboeuf au
niveau de la population totale
ce n'est pas assez élevé donc vacciner
les plus jeunes va améliorer ouverture
et la section de la part de l'ensemble
de la société en plus il ya de personnes
vaccinées mois le virus se transmet est
donc temps que le veux pas de ça n'est
pas obligatoire je pense qu'il faut le
proposer à la population la plus large
public
on l'a vu sur le sujet donné hamoud
alors juste avant le vaccin astrazeneca
est largement boudé en france il ya
également
des questions sur des effets
potentiellement indésirables sur le
vaccin plaisir biotech au niveau des
risques cardiaques récemment quel est
l'état d'esprit des belges vis-à-vis de
la vaccination d'un point de vue général
il reste assez rassuré c'est vrai que
notre ministre de la santé a clairement
banni le vaccin d'astra les
complications qui ont été observés
restent vraiment très rare d'un point de
vue médical pour un médecin ce sont des
choses qui restent de l'ordre de la
signifiance si on devait énumérer tous
les risques que qui accompagne toute
hospitalisation toute maladie ou tout
tout tout tout médication on aurait vite
peur évidemment là on parle de
vaccination à large échelle donc le
moindre incident a une répercussion très
fortes répercussions médiatiques aussi
puisque tout tout tout cela est sous la
loupe et sous le regard des médias bon
astra bien sûr des sujets à polémique
pfizer vous m'en parlez donc c'est même
pas encore je pense dans les médias en
belgique
globalement la population dans son
ensemble reste relativement sereine j'ai
encore vu récemment des gens qui avaient
reçu le vaccin d'astra première dose et
qui font pour leur deuxième dose tout à
fait serein ils sont bien compris je
pense le message ce sont des événements
excessivement rare qu'on a pu observer
chez des personnes probablement à plus
haut risque pour des raisons encore
indéterminées de santé personnels quand
on voit que dans le département français
des landes
il ya une circulation inquiétante du
variant delta du coronavirus qu'est ce
que vous vous dites qu'on
on va vers des perspectives d'avenir
grâce à l'effort collectif selon les
mots de votre premier ministre alexandre
de crau ou bien est-ce que l'inquiétude
reste de mise finalement n'ont pas
d'inquiétude fin nul ne pourra prédire
l'avenir mais on voit bien que ce virus
a commencé a muté il ya un petit temps
certaines mutations qui ne sont plus
dangereuses que d'autres il va
probablement continuer à noter un but et
pardon donc je ne suis pas vers l'ogre
ni infectiologues
mais le plus probable c'est qu'on va
continuer à se faire vacciner
donc l'effort collectif a continué mais
vu que la production du vaccin est
actuellement je dirais bien bien
intégrés et bien bien contrôlé les
vaccins vont continuer à arriver sur le
marché et la population continuera à se
faire vacciner on a parlé donc de la
troisième dose pour preuve par exemple
on verra par la suite s'il faudra
changer de vaccins mais mais moi je
reste relativement serein puisque la
population se fait vacciner et que les
vaccins arrivent sur le marché de façon
relativement aisée la production se fera
en fonction des nouveaux variants je
n'ai vraiment pas beaucoup d'inquiétude
là-dessus c'est quand même larmes
principal pour combattre la l'épidémie
ce n'est pas le confinement qui était
larmes la plus la plus efficace vous
savez toujours que j'ai été un peu
critique mais avec cela mais la
vaccination c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui doit être suivi encouragée et
soutenue surtout par le corps médical en
merci gb gêné d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecin anesthésiste et président de
l'association belge à des syndicats
médicaux